Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Kim Mills, and I'm speaking to you from APA's Technology Mind and Society Conference in Washington. This is an interdisciplinary meeting aimed at assessing current efforts to understand and shape the interactions of human beings and technology, for identifying priorities for future work, and for promoting. the exchange of ideas and collaboration among participants. Dr. Christopher Ferguson is a professor of psychology at Stetson University in DeLand, Florida. He has clinical experience in working with offender and juvenile justice populations, as well as in conducting evaluations for child protective services. His research focuses on media violence and video games in particular, and he recently
您好，欢迎收听由美国心理学会制作的播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人金·米尔斯，我正在华盛顿参加美国心理学会的技术、思想与社会会议。这是一次跨学科会议，旨在评估目前理解和塑造人类与技术互动关系的努力，确定未来工作的重点，并促进参与者之间的思想交流与合作。克里斯托弗·弗格森博士是佛罗里达州德兰市斯泰森大学的心理学教授。他在与罪犯和青少年司法群体合作方面拥有临床经验，并曾为儿童保护服务机构进行评估。他的研究重点是媒体暴力，特别是电子游戏，他最近
served as guest editor of a special issue of the APA Journal Review of General Psychology on that topic, But he's here today to talk about suicide contagion, which fits him with his interest in how political pressure, social panics, and the so-called culture wars can distort media research. Welcome, Dr. Ferguson. Thanks for having me here today. So the first question that comes to my mind is whether your research has shown that there is such a thing as suicide contagion. Yeah, that's a great question. So, I mean, it really matters. Contagent by who or what is really sort of an essential issue. So there really are three pools of research on suicide contagion.
担任了美国心理学会期刊《普通心理学评论》关于该主题特刊的客座编辑。但他今天来这里是为了谈论自杀传染，这符合他对于政治压力、社会恐慌和所谓的文化战争如何扭曲媒体研究的兴趣。欢迎您，弗格森博士。谢谢您今天邀请我。那么我脑海中浮现的第一个问题是，您的研究是否表明存在“自杀传染”这种现象。是的，这是一个很好的问题。我的意思是，这真的很重要。由谁或什么引起的传染是一个本质问题。关于自杀传染的研究确实有三个领域。
One is by peers. So if one of your friends or someone in your social environment commit suicide, does that make you more likely to commit suicide if you're kind of on that edge of considering it? The second is by news media, so coverage of actual suicides and news media. And the third is with fictional television shows like 13 Reasons Why or even heavy metal music like Ozzy Osbourne and things like that. And the research probably is pretty solid in terms of there being some sort of peer contagion type of effect, that for individuals who are at risk for suicide, having a close associate commit suicide, may elevate their risk somewhat.
一是同伴传染。如果你的朋友或社交环境中的某人自杀，这是否会让你在考虑自杀的边缘时更有可能去自杀？二是新闻媒体，即新闻媒体对实际自杀事件的报道。三是虚构的电视节目，如《十三个原因》，甚至是像奥兹·奥斯本这样的重金属音乐等。就同伴传染效应而言，研究结果相当可靠，即对于有自杀风险的个人来说，亲密伙伴的自杀可能会在一定程度上提高他们的风险。
The news media effects are a little bit dodgier, but there seems to be some research there are suggesting there may or may not be some effects with news media contagion. But I was really concerned with fictional media. Instead of looking at shows like 13 reasons why, and it's kind of like fictional media portrayals of suicide, and whether that would increase the likelihood of viewers committing suicide or thinking about suicide themselves. And the literature has been going on for several decades, so I was kind of curious of summarizing that with a meta-analytic procedure, kind of looking at what are the overall trends in the research to date. And although there's certainly some heterogeneity, there's some differences between studies in terms of whether effects seem to exist or not. Overall, my analysis suggested that the data we have currently is probably not sufficient
新闻媒体的影响稍微有些不确定，但似乎有一些研究表明新闻媒体传染可能存在，也可能不存在。但我真正关心的是虚构媒体。我研究了像《十三个原因》这样的节目，以及关于自杀的虚构媒体描述，看这是否会增加观众自杀或产生自杀念头的可能性。相关文献已经持续了几十年，所以我很想通过元分析程序来总结这些研究，看看迄今为止研究的总体趋势是什么。虽然肯定存在一些异质性，即不同研究在效应是否存在方面存在差异，但总体而言，我的分析表明我们目前拥有的数据可能不足以
to support these kind of concerns that we're having about shows like 13 reasons why. There does not seem to be a conclusive body of evidence to suggest that suicide contagion happens through fictional media at the very least. So there was a lot of publicity last year around the article that was published by, I think it was the Journal of the American Medical Association, we got that right, that saw a big spike around the time of the broadcast and what they found was a lot of people doing internet searches for suicide. Was that not a good piece of research?
支持我们对《十三个原因》这类节目的担忧。至少没有确凿的证据表明自杀传染是通过虚构媒体发生的。去年，我想是《美国医学会杂志》发表了一篇文章，引起了广泛关注，我们没记错的话，文章指出在节目播出期间，关于自杀的互联网搜索量激增。那项研究做得不好吗？
It's not so much that it wasn't a good piece of research. It's more that it wasn't clear from those searches whether those individuals who were doing those searches were intending to commit suicide necessarily. Or if they were curious about the topic or even may have been seeking help because it they had been thinking about suicide previously. So it wasn't really sure that those searches translated into real behavior. And the example might be is that in all likelihood,
与其说那项研究做得不好，不如说从那些搜索中无法明确判断搜索者是否真的有自杀意图。或者他们只是对这个话题感到好奇，甚至可能是因为之前有过自杀念头而在寻求帮助。所以，并不能确定这些搜索转化为实际行为。举个例子，很有可能，
after, of course, we've had a lot of news recently about gun violence and tragic shootings, that it's very likely that after a tragic shooting occurs, you see a lot more searches about gun violence, mass shootings, so on and so forth. But that doesn't mean that the majority of those individuals are likely to go out and commit those shootings as well. So it seems to be the same sort of an issue.
当然，最近我们听到了很多关于枪支暴力和悲剧性枪击事件的新闻，很可能在悲剧性枪击事件发生后，你会看到更多关于枪支暴力、大规模枪击事件等的搜索。但这并不意味着大多数搜索者也可能去实施这些枪击事件。所以这似乎是同样的问题。
people were doing a lot more searches about suicide and suicide related issues. But it doesn't seem to be that that was an indication that those individuals were inclined to actually engage in suicide or that that translated into an increased risk of suicide behaviors among viewers. Did you look at all into the kinds of messages that the producers are putting on the program now
人们确实进行了更多关于自杀和自杀相关问题的搜索。但这似乎并不表明这些人倾向于真正实施自杀，或者这转化为观众中自杀行为风险的增加。您是否研究过制片人现在在节目中加入的那些信息，
to kind of warn people? I mean, there's some concern about triggering, does it help if there's some? if there's some message at the beginning of the program or at the end of the program for resources? Yeah, I mean, they can be helpful for people who are maybe offended by content, you know, sort of warm people of what's coming
用来提醒人们？我的意思是，人们担心会产生诱发作用，如果在节目开始或结束时提供资源信息，会有帮助吗？是的，对于那些可能被内容冒犯的人来说，这些信息是有帮助的，你知道，可以提醒他们即将出现的内容，
so that they're not surprised by it. I think at this point, there are probably relatively few people to learn, who would learn that 13 reasons why is about suicide, so it's probably not, you know, in that sense, it's probably not a huge deal. It's always good to have people to be informed in terms of whether they want to decide, they want to be exposed to a particular content issue or not.
这样他们就不会感到惊讶。我认为在这一点上，可能很少有人不知道《十三个原因》是关于自杀的，所以从这个意义上说，这可能不是什么大不了的事。让人们了解他们是否想要接触特定的内容问题，这总是一件好事。
But in terms of trigger warnings, as you mentioned, being sort of a fix for possible effects, there actually was some research that I'd come across at a conference a year or two ago that actually suggested that oftentimes trigger warnings can actually increase people's anxiety about content, so have kind of a paradoxical effect. And they weren't looking at suicide theme media.
但正如你提到的，关于触发警告是否能作为可能影响的补救措施，我确实在这一两年前的一次会议上看到了一些研究，实际上表明触发警告往往会增加人们对内容的焦虑，从而产生一种悖论效应。而且他们研究的不是自杀主题的媒体。
They were looking more like even like Shakespeare novels and sexual content and violent content. But that oftentimes if you just sort of expose people to something, they don't think it's necessarily a huge deal. But if you warn them about it in advance, then they actually are sort of primed to worry about it and may actually have a bit more of a written emotional reaction to it than if you had just left it alone to some extent.
他们研究的更多是像莎士比亚小说、性内容和暴力内容。但通常如果你只是让人们接触某些东西，他们并不认为这是什么大不了的事。但如果你提前警告他们，他们实际上会被引导去担心它，并且可能比你完全不加干预时产生更强烈的负面情绪反应。
It depends on what the content is probably. If it's super shocking, the trigger warning might help. If it's maybe not so shocking, then it might actually be kind of paradoxical in terms of its effect. Did you look at contagion in other realms? I mean, there's a lot of writing research around, oh, I don't know, I mean, school shootings, for example, and whether those happen to be contagious,
这可能取决于具体内容是什么。如果内容非常令人震惊，触发警告可能会有帮助。如果内容不是那么令人震惊，那么它的效果可能会产生悖论。您是否研究过其他领域的传染？我的意思是，有很多关于，我不知道，比如校园枪击案，以及它们是否具有传染性，
or even fashion trends or things that people do with the stock market, for example. Right, yeah. Well, this study was limited just to the fictional media suicide contagion issues. Of course, there is a lot of discussion with these tragic shootings about the issue of gun violence and the possibility
甚至是时尚潮流或人们在股市中的行为，等等。对，是的。好吧，这项研究仅限于虚构媒体的自杀传染问题。当然，关于这些悲剧性枪击事件，有很多关于枪支暴力问题的讨论，以及
that news media coverage of school shootings or mass shootings may actually serve as a motivating factor for some of these shooters. There actually is not a lot of really good data on that. So they have now been a lot of studies looking at whether the frequency of gun violence increases or decreases after news coverage. So a lot of that still is very speculative. Some of that is perhaps based on a misimpression that the majority of mass shooters are out for attention. appear to be. So there have certainly been examples of like the Sandy Hook shooter or the Virginia
新闻媒体对校园枪击案或大规模枪击案的报道可能实际上成为一些枪手动机因素的可能性。关于这一点，实际上并没有太多非常好的数据。因此，现在有很多研究在观察枪支暴力的频率在新闻报道后是增加还是减少。所以其中很多仍然是非常推测性的。其中一些可能基于一种错误的印象，即大多数大规模枪击者是为了博取关注。确实有像桑迪胡克枪手或弗吉尼亚
Tech shooter who referred back to Columbine for instance. So there seems to be sometime at least some identification effect between some shooters. But you don't necessarily see that with all of them or even necessarily the majority. So I'm not sure that for instance taking steps like not using shooters' names is necessarily going to have a big effect on gun violence or mass shootings. But on the other hand, there isn't really any. harm either in avoiding using shooters names so if there's no harm might as well do it I suppose you know not on the off chance maybe there's some small effect there but it's probably not going to be the the main thing that solves issues like
理工大学枪手那样引用科伦拜恩枪击案的例子。所以，在一些枪手之间似乎至少存在某种认同效应。但你并不一定在所有人身上，甚至不一定在大多数人身上看到这一点。所以我并不确定，例如采取不使用枪手名字等措施，一定会对枪支暴力或大规模枪击事件产生重大影响。但另一方面，避免使用枪手名字也没有什么坏处，所以如果没有坏处，我想不妨这样做，你知道，万一有一点点小影响呢，但这可能不会是解决像
gun violence or mass shootings so what are the next steps in terms of research for the social contagion yeah yeah well we need a lot better more transparent and open science research has been kind of a common theme in media research in general, including violent video game research and body image research and other fields that a lot of the research have been done in the past was not very transparent Some of it isn't replicating very well when people coming and trying to replicate some of those studies So a lot of things that we thought were sort of absolutely true maybe 15 years ago or 20 years ago are now proving very difficult to replicate so we're really in need
枪支暴力或大规模枪击事件等问题的主要手段。那么社会传染研究的下一步是什么？是的，我们需要更好、更透明和开放的科学研究。这在媒体研究中一直是一个共同的主题，包括暴力电子游戏研究、身体形象研究和其他领域，过去所做的很多研究并不透明。当人们试图重复其中一些研究时，有些研究结果无法很好地复现。所以我们15年前或20年前认为绝对正确的事情，现在证明很难复现，所以我们确实需要
in this field and in other media-related fields for a lot of really solid, well-designed, pre-registered, transparent, open science research. And that was one of the interesting things with this meta-analysis I conducted with this field, is that a lot of the studies were okay, but there were a lot of common issues. Like with a lot of the survey designs, they would ask about TV shows, kids had watched, and then ask them how they felt about suicide. You know, are you thinking about suicide?
在这个领域以及其他媒体相关领域进行大量真正扎实、设计良好、预注册、透明、开放的科学研究。这也是我在这项元分析中发现的一个有趣之处，很多研究还可以，但存在许多共同问题。比如在很多调查设计中，他们会询问孩子们看过的电视节目，然后询问他们对自杀的感受。你知道，你在考虑自杀吗？
And it's not that hard to guess the hypothesis of that study. And sometimes that can change people's behavior one way or another. So it would be really good to see a lot more studies that are trying to get away from that, masking the hypothesis better, following people over longer periods of time to see what the long-term effects are. And I think that would help elucidate whether these types of effects do or do not exist in this field. So we're actually trying to do a little bit of that at Stetson University.
猜测该研究的假设并不难。有时这会以某种方式改变人们的行为。因此，如果能看到更多试图摆脱这种模式的研究将会非常好，比如更好地掩盖假设，对人们进行更长时间的跟踪，以观察长期影响。我认为这将有助于阐明这些类型的效应在该领域是否存在。所以我们实际上正在斯泰森大学尝试做一点这方面的工作。
And we're just now starting a longitudinal study of youth and their viewing habits and in mood related issues including suicide. Great. I look forward to seeing that when you get it published. Same here. Yeah, all right. Well, thank you very much Dr. Ferguson for joining us today. Well, thank you for having me on. I appreciate it. It's a pleasure. Thank you for joining our podcast. Speaking of psychology is part of the APA podcast network which includes other great podcasts such as APA Journal's Dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research and progress notes
我们刚刚开始一项关于青少年及其观看习惯以及包括自杀在内的情绪相关问题的纵向研究。太棒了。我很期待看到你发表这项研究。我也是。好的，非常感谢弗格森博士今天加入我们。谢谢你们邀请我。我很感激。这是我的荣幸。感谢您收听我们的播客。《心理学谈话》是美国心理学会播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他优秀的播客，例如美国心理学会期刊关于最新和最令人兴奋的心理学研究的对话，以及《进展笔记》，
which discusses the practice of psychology. You can find all APA podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, www.spokenof psychology.org, to listen to more episodes and see more resources on the topics we discuss. Thanks again for joining us. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association, and this is Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
该节目讨论心理学实践。您可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方找到所有美国心理学会的播客。您也可以访问我们的网站www.spokenofpsychology.org，收听更多剧集并查看我们讨论主题的更多资源。再次感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯，这是《心理学谈话》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。